A ton has been made of a recent report that
says, Oh, oh, a $15 minimum wage would destroy
more than 1 million jobs. And this report
is being cited by right-wingers all over the
country as proof proof that a $15 minimum
wage would be terrible for the country and
we shouldn't do it. And in fact, this is being
used to argue that we shouldn't even have
a minimum wage at all because it's an artificial
price floor and it's bad for the economy.
So I want to actually talk this through with
you today because you might be shocked to
hear this, but the right wing reaction to
this study makes no sense at all and is patently
dishonest. So let's start with what the study
says. Right now, the federal minimum wage
is $7 and 25 cents an hour, which is insane.
I often forget about this because I live in
Massachusetts, but federally, even though
many states have higher minimum wages federally,
the minimum wage is $7 and 25 cents an hour.
The study by the CBO looked at increases to
$10 an hour, $12 an hour, and $15 an hour
by 2025 we're just going to focus on the 15
an hour to keep it simple. Today, increasing
the minimum wage to $15 by 2025 the CBO study
found would increase the effective net wages
of 17 million people who would otherwise be
earning under $15 an hour.
That's good news. In addition to raising the
wages of 17 million, who would be earning
under $15 an hour, it would also push up slightly
the wages of another 10 million people who
are earning right around 15 or we'll be earning
right around $15 an hour in 2025 so 27 million
people in total will have higher wages as
a result of this. A minimum wage increase.
However, about 1.3 million people would be
moved a a would would not have a job who otherwise
would people, it doesn't necessarily mean
people will be fired, but it means that in
2025 with a $15 minimum wage, there are 1.3
million people who would otherwise have jobs
who will not because of that minimum wage
increase and it would have a slightly inflationary
effect on prices overall. So first of all,
we have to understand that these numbers,
the CBO admits are uncertain because the CBO
straight up admits, we don't know how responsive
unemployment or employment are to changes
in the minimum wage.
They admit there is a lot of uncertainty about
how sensitive is employment relative to a
change in the minimum wage. Is it extremely
sensitive or is it only slightly sensitive?
In addition, there are other studies published
at the exact same time that say there would
not be this effect of 1.3 million jobs that
would not exist were it not for that $15 minimum
wage, but for this discussion, let's imagine
that these numbers are 100% accurate from
the CBO. The question becomes does it make
sense to increase the minimum wage to $15
or not? So the most childish argument is any
policy that leads to any job loss is a bad
policy. Now this is an outrageous position
to take because almost any economic policy
decision has some gains in some losses and
you basically can't do anything. I mean, the
government would not be able to do any economic
policy if the rule was, if any jobs are lost,
we don't do it.
So that's not even a serious argument. It
is true that to come in and in some states
you would be effectively more than doubling
the minimum wage. That is going to affect
employers more if the wage than if the wage
had been increasing with inflation all along.
And that's part of the problem here. We are
so far behind on minimum wage increases in
states that still have a minimum wage that
is equal to the federal minimum wage of seven
25 that we now have a situation, we're going
to $15 would more than double the minimum
wage in some states. So this is how you have
an adult conversation. There's a benefit to
the policy, but it also comes with a cost.
Is the cost too high? Is the cost acceptable,
is it low? And we get a lot more benefit than
we lose by putting in place this policy.
When you look at where a $15 minimum wage
would have the biggest impact, you immediately
see that the gains will be in the places where
people much more desperately needed in terms
of wage growth and the job losses will also
be disproportionately in the places that are
so far behind on the minimum wage right now
that going to $15 would be effectively doubling
the minimum wage in their state. So can I
answer for you whether it makes sense in your
state to have this tradeoff? I can't really
do that. Can I answer whether 27 million people
getting a raise and pulling about 2 million
people out of poverty, is that a valuable
trade off? Is that a fair trade off for 1.3
million not having jobs in 2025 who otherwise
would know? I can't really tell you that.
I mean, each of us has different priorities.
What I can tell you definitively is that this
exposes the bigger truth about the minimum
wage, which I've been talking about for years
now.
The first bigger truth is that this is really
an issue that probably has to vary state by
state. And what I mean by that is that because
the cost of living is so drastically different
in different parts of the country and even
within states, like for example in New York
state, which has New York City and extremely
rural low cost of living areas upstate, a
living wage in some low cost of living states
would be too low to even be a reasonable minimum
wage in a place that has a high cost of living
like New York City or Boston, San Francisco,
Los Angeles. So I question even handling this
as a federal issue. Even though a seven 25
federal minimum wage is outrageously low and
that needs to change. The second bigger truth
here is that this once again gets to what
I said to a call or last week when they said
does the $15 minimum wage or does is universal
basic income?
Does that really solve the problem that we
are dealing with? And the answer is that these
are not solutions to our broken economy, particularly
with automation coming 40 years of productivity
gains going to the richest people while the
bottom half have effectively stagnant wages,
increased inequality. The solution is not
going to be a $15 minimum wage. The solution
is not going to be universal basic income.
Now that doesn't mean don't do them. Okay,
but what it does mean is that we need to all
understand to really solve our problems, we've
got to be thinking way bigger and almost none
of our politicians are now Andrew Yang is
actually talking about this. I just don't
agree with all of his proposals. I think that
the VAT tax proposal he has, that's a hugely
regressive tax. I don't like that. I think
that the implementation of some of his other
ideas is the wrong one, but he is at least
talking about it.
Last thing, really important to understand
on the backend that again, the numbers we
used for our discussion today might be totally
wrong because there's a university of California
study which says that a $15 minimum wage by
2024 simply would not cause the level of job
losses that the CBO study claims. So there
is a conflict there, but it doesn't matter
because none of it solves the reality that
we have a broken relationship between humans
and work. This includes this average 40 hour,
five day a week work week. This includes the
connection between work and health care that
we have and it includes the fact that the
economy values at zero a lot of work that
has value like raising kids, taking care of
our elderly parents, volunteering in our communities,
and whether the minimum wage is 10 12 or $15
that is
still going to be a problem.